pace is a student staff initiative here
on campus aimed at raising awareness for
civic engagement for Carnegie Mellon
students faculty and staff every year we
choose an annual theme to be able to
focus our educational programming around
and this year we've chosen the theme of
food insecurity just particularly
meaningful given the work that we're
doing with stop hunger now we're an
international hunger relief agency we
operate under a crazy vision of a world
without hunger and our mission is simply
to end hunger in our lifetime
the parent company is a global food
company so eliminating global hunger is
a priority for us and we have had our
micronutrient campaign for about 15
years and over time we've proven that
you know with our micronutrients we can
cure children of malnutrition and break
cycles of poverty in the developing
world so we want to create a movement
with stop hunger now and get other
people involved so that's why we invited
Carnegie Mellon to join us in the fight
against hunger so this was exactly
aligned with what we were hoping to
educate students about this year and I
mean it's been a great it's been well
received specially exciting this event
is particularly meaningful because of
the large profile and the number of
students that we've been able to
mobilize and to get here this morning I
think we've got over 600 people in there
I having a great time as they package
and they're gonna end up doing over a
hundred and twenty thousand meals today
pretty amazing so we try to do a wide
variety of events we also do things like
documentary screenings and book clubs so
we really try to come at really
complicated social issues like food
insecurity from multiple vantage point
so that people can really understand the
complexities of the issue and be able to
get a sense of how they can get engaged
and try to take action to compat food
insecurity and global hunger
you